michel sapin le ministre des finances
est l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
monsieur le ministre dont sortent et
merci d'être avec nous alors que
l'incertitude et l'embarras domine plus
que jamais semble-t-il cinq jours après
le vote britannique première partie de
preuve par trois comment le break site
doit désormais entrer dans les faits au
plus vite
avez-vous dit et comment réinventer
l'europe deuxième partie avec stéphanie
le rouge de l' agence france-presse
notre partenaire pour preuve par trois
quels sont les nouveaux défis lancés à
l'économie française par le break site
que faut-il craindre
et puis vous répondrais également sur la
contestation sociale dans cette nouvelle
journée de mobilisation contre la loi
travaille notamment à paris enfin
troisième partie de l'émission tout à
l'heure avec michaël szames s de public
sénat comment françois hollande peut-il
regagner la confiance des français à dix
mois de la fin de son mandat alors que
bien sûr on l'a entendu la primaire de
la gauche est sur les rails en tous les
cas en chantier embarras je le disais
incertitudes provoquées par le vote pour
le break site mais également
stupéfaction à vous allez nous dire car
on découvre que les partisans
britannique du livre n'avait vraiment
rien prévu
rien ne presse pour eux aujourd'hui et
au blâme anti europe 1 qu'on a entendu
pendant des semaines et bien succès par
exemple dans la bouche de boris johnson
la demande de conserver l'accès au
marché unique alors est ce que vous êtes
estomaqué michel sapin par tant de
légèreté triste mac et non mais on
savait bien qu'au fond les arguments
utilisés par là comme ailleurs par les
partisans du lives étaient des arguments
entendus terme grossier à la serpe
parfois même carrément mensonger parfois
même des mensonges qui ont été reconnues
aujourd'hui par les partisans du livre
donc on savait bien que le débat au fond
avait quitté le domaine du rationnel
est ce que c'est bon pour l'économie
britannique ou pas quelles sont les
conséquences quelles places pour la
grande bretagne dans le monde des
arguments rationnels est parfaitement
légitime pour ne venir que sur le
terrain de l'irrationnel et quand on est
arrivés sur le terrain de l'irrationnel
on n'est jamais sûr de ce qui peut se
passer mais quand on entend par exemple
l'ancien maire de londres assuré
aujourd'hui que l'aco
opération entre l'europe et la grande
bretagne va se renforcer comment est-ce
que vous rêvez c'est l'idée a aussi qui
était une illusion pour ne pas dire un
mensonge qui a été longtemps porté par
les partisans de la sortie de la grande
bretagne l'union européenne c'est que ça
ne changerait rien qu'au fond ils
perdraient les inconvénients et
garderaient tous les avantages qu'ils
restent là moi j'en nous n'avons pas
cessé de le redire
pendant tout le débat que par définition
leur décision aurait des conséquences et
des conséquences sur la grande bretagne
et 10 rebonds la grande bretagne ou au
détriment de la grande-bretagne femmes
et nous n'accueillons nous parler nous
n'allons pas de nous changer de langage
dont c'était le roux les partisans du
bail cit se sont piégés eux mêmes tous
les cas ils apparaissent aujourd'hui
vous le dis j'ai très bien vous même
comme totalement démuni devant leur
propre victoire comme si au fond il
aurait préféré la défaite comme qu'ils
auraient apprécié en tous les cas les
plus compliqués il avait préféré mais
non quand on pose une question ou peuple
un peuple décide mais le peuple décide
pour toujours est ce que vous rêvez par
exemple va avec le brix icm se produise
pardon mais on peut il faut pas rentrer
la construction est menacée la
déconstruction c'est quand même beaucoup
plus compliqué c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que un traité qui fait avancer
la sait rien des gens qui évoquent
l'hypothèse en europe et même en grande
bretagne d'un nouveau référendum
quelqu'un dit vous m'aimez jeu j'entends
même que je lis parfois même dans les
pages des journaux français des gens qui
sont sur cette thèse vous ça n'aurait
rien changé
non ça change oui le premier dé respect
qu'on doit avoir pour la démocratie
c'est de respecter le vote du peuple
britannique
il peut peut-être le regretter
aujourd'hui ce peuple peut-être qu il le
regrettera j'en suis à corriger nos
mains non il a pris une décision
cette décision doit être mise en oeuvre
c'est toujours en arrière possible
mais il ya toujours des retours en
arrière n'y a pas de retour en arrière
là ils ont pris une décision
cette décision doit être mise en oeuvre
vous rendez compte
déjà c'est pas ça vous parliez vous même
de cette situation peu compliqué
indécise incertaine mais on va rajouter
de la certitude a la certitude
déjà aujourd'hui on va en parler oui il
faut essayer de maîtriser cette
incertitude il faut essayer de la limité
dans le temps là elle est servie à juger
la main ça c'est un corner suivant les
passagers s'avère le seul
alors vrai danger pour l'europe c'est la
certitude c'est un danger maximale pour
la grande bretagne mais ça peut être
aussi à nos jours nous donc ne rajoutons
pas de la certitude alors une décision a
été prise par le peuple britannique
cette décision doit être mise en oeuvre
le plus rapidement la russie est ce que
vous êtes aimée par exemple que david
cameron qui s'est lancé dans un pari un
peu d'être insensé de aurait déjà dû
démissionner et chez vous vous enfoncez
les valses et leur vie politique
c'est vrai que ce qu'a décidé cameron il
les regarde et on a décidé à l'époque
pour des raisons internes à son propre
parti c'est quand même bon on voit bien
combien il est piégé lui-même en
aboutissant au bout du compte à une
décision du peuple qu'il ne souhaitait
pas véritablement il s'est piégé ou ses
autres pris à son propre piège
il ya aujourd'hui il y as peut-être des
contraintes politiques je veux bien le
comprendre
d'ailleurs chez les travaillistes comme
chez les conservateurs
moi je vois bien le périph l'explosion
d'un train d'exploser comme je pense que
les fluxs faut s'organiser une mise en
cause par une partie des travaillistes
de la faible implication de leurs
leaders dans ce domaine mais donc du
côté des conservateurs on voit bien
aussi qu'il ya des cassures qui a des
questions profondes et donc qu'ils aient
besoin eux de temps pour réformer alors
que l'état en démissionnant
mais les problèmes politiques des partis
pour l'anglais et ils n'ont pas à être
supporté par le reste de l'europe
d'accord alors écouter à propos du
divorce rapide ou point de vue du
président du conseil
aujourd'hui donald tusk et puis
david cameron qui donc temporise
l'europe est prête à entamer le
processus de divorce dès aujourd'hui
avec aucun enthousiasme comme vous
pouvez l'imaginer ça car ce n'est pas le
scénario dont nous rêvions la grande
bretagne va quitter l'union européenne
mais je veux que cette procédure soit
aussi constructive que possible alors la
position de la france elle a été
affirmée très tôt d'ailleurs par
françois hollande y compris face à
c'est-à-dire la position aujourd'hui de
l'ensemble des partenaires européens
notamment des pays fondateurs mais pas
de démo la partition c'est la position
de tous ceux qui aujourd'hui font les
décisions en europe
elle se des résultats très simplement on
ne peut pas traîner traîner ses de la
servitude de la certitude sont des
inconvénients qui peuvent être graves
grave d'abord pour la grande bretagne où
il grave pour nous aussi donc on ne
traîne pas et si c'est là dessus que
c'est fait le raisonnement des
responsables européens
si les britanniques pensent pouvoir
commencer les négociations sur qu'est ce
qui se passe après sans avoir enclenché
la procédure dite de divorce mais non la
clarté c'est vous avez décidez vous
enclenchez d'accor s'est nourri ce que
vous avez enclenché on discute
la grande bretagne va pas rester un pays
sans aucune attache avec non plus vous
dit non mais ils peuvent pas nous forcer
non plus donc on est dans une situation
où aujourd'hui il n'y aura aucune
négociation sur la suite tant que la
grande bretagne n'aura pas déclencher va
que toute procédure de divorce
et je vous assure oui que c'est ce qui
va créer le plus de problèmes à la
grande bretagne parce que ça crée une
incertitude monstrueuse pour l'ensemble
des acteurs économiques
en grande bretagne c'est l'intérêt
profond de la grande bretagne que de
commencer le plus tôt possible
la négociation est donc d'enclencher le
plus tôt possible
le prix de la précédente on leur dit
vous allez ajouter de l'incertitude et
déjà vous qui allez regarder aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui même regarder un peu ce qui
s'est passé sur les marchés des marchés
à bouge ça va dans un sens un jour à
l'autre donc il faut regarder ça dans le
moyen long terme
enfin on voit qu'aujourd'hui la
certitude elle sait pèse sur le dos des
anglais des britanniques
et pour le pensez vous aller nous le
dire dans un instant bien aujourd'hui a
mis en garde nos futurs ex-partenaires
pas de divorce à la carte on écoute la
chancelière
nous allons nous assurer que ces
négociations ne se font pas sur le
principe du à la carte est moins
elle souffre il doit et il y aura une
différence concrète entre les pays qui
veulent rester membre de la famille
européenne ou non alors là encore il ya
des limites à ne pas franchir
oui nous c'est parfois montre d'ailleurs
là la cohérence des positions des
principaux responsables européens
c'est exactement ce que dit avec ses
propres mots le président de la
république ou ce que disent ils un salon
où d'autres responsables monsieur renzi
ou d'autres responsables on commence par
enclencher la procédure de divorce et on
tergiverse pas et après on discute
évidemment du type de lien j'avais y
avoir entre la grande-bretagne et
l'europe
on va voir ses relations en conséquence
bien sûr un vote de cette nature ça a
des conséquences
on doit il faut l'assumer faut l'assumer
faut l'assumer alors donc on verra ce
qui se passe dans les jours et les
semaines qui viennent les mois puisque
quand même que ça va prendre quand même
un minimum de temps michel sapin il ya
une autre question qui se pose
aujourd'hui comment réinventer la france
l'europe selon la formule aujourd'hui de
manuel valls qui s'est livrée d'ailleurs
à l'assemblée nationale à une sorte
d'autocritique sur la construction telle
qu'elle a été conduite jusqu'à présent
on écoute l'erreur historique serait de
croire que ce référendum ne regarde que
les britanniques non c'est de l'avenir
de chacun des peuples de l'union qu'il
s'agit ce vote montre une certaine
manière le malaise des peuples il doute
depuis longtemps de l'europe
ils ne comprennent pas ce qu'elle fait
ne vois pas ce qu'elle leur apporte
ils ont le sentiment qu'elle impose ses
choix et jouent systématiquement contre
leurs intérêts l'europe se fera avec les
peuples sinon elle se disloquera alors
on avait rarement entendu une critique
aussi forte de la construction
européenne dans la bouche de l'exécutif
français
ça nous est arrivé à tous - en
particulier de dire des choses de même
de même nature mais quand même à la
remise en cause de l'europe
nan mais quand même on a entendu le
premier ministre dénonce et les thèses
ultralibérales et l'austérité budgétaire
fait que vous mettez en oeuvre vos mains
alors qu'actuellement pas donc il n'y a
pas d'austérité en france si vous l'êtes
vous explique ce que cette austérité
on va aller en grèce on va aller au
portugal on va aller en espagne mais je
n'accepte absolument pas la critique dit
de l'austérité en france on est une
famille quéveau sérieux ou dirrig
peut-être mais
les rigueurs volet politique sérieuse
qui consiste à faire en sorte que nos
déficits n'explose pas de les diminuer
pour maîtriser notre dette vous allez
c'est un langage que je tiendra
indépendamment alors entendre dès qu'on
est sous le joug de bruce jeu donc je
vous réponds que je ferais la même
politique indépendamment de l'europe
parce qu'elle est bonne pour la france
donc nous faisons en france ce qui est
bon pour la france
et ceci est cohérent avec les politiques
qui sont par ailleurs menées
vous souhaitez en europe mais je le fais
parce que c'est bon pour la france
vous n'imaginez pas les français ne
veulent pas aujourd'hui que la dette
qu'ils reportent qu'on reporte sur leurs
enfants continuent à augmenter
donc il faut évidemment maîtriser dont
on a une politique mais j'étais sérieux
cette multi à terre ça y est nécessaire
dans tous les pays qui par ailleurs la
salmonelle vous rendez d'équipage la
même jeu n'auront aucun compte à
bruxelles c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe
heureusement donc ces derniers un
dialogue avec bruxelles qui est chargée
de vérifier que tous les pays ont des
politiques cohérentes vous pouvez pas
avoir la même monnaie l'euro est par
ailleurs avoir des politiques
budgétaires complètement différente donc
c'est normal 18 d entre nous pour rendre
les choses le plus grand rêve d'ailleurs
on aurait besoin qu'il y ait de la
cohérence aussi dans d'autres domaines
qu'il y ait la cohérence dans le domaine
fiscal
une harmonisation fiscale qui est de la
cohérence dans le domaine social une
harmonisation sociale ou 10 s est battu
par exemple dans un autre ministère
contre les travailleurs détachés les
facilités offertes et on sait que ces
directives sont dévastateurs amoureux
mais bon le bâtiment français également
même l'industrie est aujourd'hui
attaquée alors jusque là on a péché par
naïveté je sais pas si c'est par naïveté
en tous les cas à d'autres moments dans
les années 90 ont été adopté des
directives dont on voit aujourd'hui
qu'elle provoque des dégâts
considérables
il ya bien des corrections de terre qui
est sainte donc et des corrections de
tir qui s'imposent pour il est
parfaitement légitime sa carrière c'est
ce que 2 propose le premier ministre ya
juste titre et quand il dit la relation
au peuple il a parfaitement raison
regardez qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui vous avez une europe qui est
depuis 2007 2008 est encore dans la
crise grosso modo qui n'a pas retrouvé
le niveau de richesse individuelle
d'avant la crise on vous rendez compte
la longueur presque dix ans jamais
l'europe n'avait connu ça depuis 1945
comprends qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
interrogations on comprend qu'ils aient
un salon deux peuples qui se disent mais
peut-être que c'est à cause de l'europe
même si en l'occurrence c'est il faut
pas faire reporter par l'europe toutes
les responsabilités nous avons aussi
chacun d'entre nous nos propres
responsabilités
chaque gouvernement dans chacun des pays
et le tout depuis dix ans donc il doit
assumer vous prenez vos les regardant
vous prenez votre part alors j'imagine
pour le début du quinquennat
à chacun sa part de respecter vite et je
pense ne l'ont fait ce qui était
nécessaire mais parce que on avait un
dérapage monstrueux de nos déficits
parce qu'on nous a laissé une france où
je vous parle voilà cathy caricatural
véritablement dans un état désastreux
quand vous voulez me faire en sorte
qu'un état désastreux soit corrigé ça
peut faire mal pas alors après la part
d'autocritique ont entendu quand même
dans la bouche des communes et je vais
vous faire entendre la critique d'arnaud
montebourg dans une interview au monde
ce soir lui il estime que
qu'il faut dénoncer la politique
d'austérité extrémistes et autoritaire
dictée par une europe antidémocratique
et il accuse françois hollande en fait
d'avoir appliqué la politique de la
droite allemande alors que lui
répondez-vous il répète la même chose
depuis déjà quatre ans oui mais là il se
sent un peu porté par ce qui se passe
c'est important devait le peuple il est
un de plus parmi beaucoup d'autres à
jaillir à dire des raids dans le slogan
il y en a assez des slogans il y en a
assez des slogans ces slogans la
n'apporte rien
c'est comme ceux celui qui dit il faut
absolument un nouveau traité sympathique
un nouveau traité mais ce qui
m'intéresse moi c'est qu'est ce qu'il ya
dans le nouveau traité
il a d'autres qui disent ils feront un
référendum mais un référendum pour un
référendum plein mais ce qui compte
c'est la question pourquoi j'ai mexique
françois hollande a bien orienté le roi
a cédé slogan que ce soit des slogans
critique vis-à-vis de l'europe où que ce
soit des slogans qui on s'en serait
l'europe
on peut pas simplement sauter comme
disait quelqu'un a son siège en disant
europe europe
ça n'apporte rien de concret aujourd'hui
au peuple justement c'est ça le divorce
des peuples avec ce qu'on appelle
l'europe
il leur veulent du concret il y en a
ras-le-bol des slogans anti ou des
slogans pro il faut être dans le concret
concret c'est mettre fin au dumping
fiscal qui peut exister d'un pays à
l'autre avec la même monnaie être
concret c'est mettre fin à une forme de
dumping social qui peut exister au
détriment des travailleurs mais aussi au
détriment de des entreprises et des
pouvoirs limités faute valeurs
fondamentales de l'europe qui notamment
la librairie d'agents et la valeur
faudra des capitaux la libre circulation
anglais chose mais comme toute liberté
comme toute liberté elle est encadrée
elle est régulé sinon on n'est pas dans
la liberté
comme disait l'autre on est dans la
liberté du renard libre dans le
poulailler libre
alors ça c'est pas notre vision de rats
si on assiste effectivement à une
réinvention de l'europe ou alors si on
assiste à sa mort écouter marine le pen
elle elle qu'on parle l'union actuelle à
l'urss morte de ses propres
contradictions at elle déclaré
aujourd'hui la présidente du front
national si vous aimez dénoncé les
slogans à wissous
pardon je croyais
vous qui avez fait c'est vous qui avez
fait le travail
oui j'écoute même plus parce que cela
aussi autour des slogans on est dans une
répétition concret elle veut un
référendum qu'elle me dise qu'elle est
la question posée je ne la connais pas
qu'elle dise les solutions qu'elles
apportent je ne les connais pas là aussi
il faut sortir de ces dénonciations
simple simpliste qui on l'a vu
d'ailleurs en grande bretagne provoque
beaucoup de dégâts il ya eu beaucoup de
simplisme dans le débat en
grande-bretagne et dans le débat en
défaveur de la grande bretagne dans
l'union européenne et c'est ce simplisme
là qui est en train de faire aujourd'hui
des dégâts vous avez commencé par là
inédit vous rendez compte
peut-être qu'il s'était pas il n'avait
pas complètement peser le poids de leurs
arguments et les conséquences eh bien
c'est la même chose moi même le pen elle
a pas tout à fait véritablement peser
les conséquences de ce qu'elle propose
que c'est la nouvelle fracture politique
en france qui remplace la fracture
droite gauche
les pro et les anti européens est ce que
on assiste à ça aujourd'hui dans notre
pays fracture mais c'est un sujet par un
clivage un nouveau clivage je peux le
dire autrement oui parce que c'est pas
nouveau que y ait des débats au sein de
la gauche ou qu'il ait débat au sein de
la droite sur la question européenne ont
la vue y compris en 2005 dans d'autres
conditions
mais aujourd'hui j'ai une nouvelle ligne
de partage passez une nuit mais en tout
cas c'est un point sur lequel on peut se
rassembler donc c'est pas une ligne de
partage un point sur lequel il peut y
avoir des que des connexions légitime
entre les uns et les autres mais à
partir chacun de sa vision a une vision
de gauche de l'europe
d'accord la confiance à l'europe c'est
la vision qui n' a pas une étape vers la
loire position une recomposition georges
éthiques
je suis pas de ceux qui pensent que en
abolissant toutes les frontières entre
la droite et la gauche
on arrive à reconstruire l'avenir je
pense que c'est même l'un vers ce parce
qu'on crée de la confusion regarder
toute cette confusion partout
non vous mettre fin à la confusion donc
nous rajoute ou pas là où ça l'est de la
confusion à la confusion
michel sapin deuxième partie de preuves
par 3 quels sont les nouveaux défis
lancés à l'économie française par le
brésil vous avez dit ça ne pourrait être
sans conséquence et puis alors donc que
faut-il craindre vous allez répondre
également à stéphanie le rouge qui
arrive sur la contestation sociale en
cette nouvelle journée
et de mobilisation contre la loi
travaille d'abord on va écouter
christopher dembik economista sexo
banques
l'impact du breakbeat sur la situation
économique française sera relativement
limitée a priori ce qu'il est important
de souligner c'est qu'il ya une
incertitude aux vrais problèmes
l'incertitude quant aux réglementations
qui vont régir la relation entre le
royaume-uni et le reste de l'union
européenne
plus il y aura une incertitude
concernant le calendrier des
négociations plus évidemment cela aura
un impact néfaste sur la croissance
française
mais aujourd'hui en l'état actuel des
choses il est strictement impossible de
quantifier éventuellement l'impact on
sait juste que ça pourrait ralentir
légèrement la croissance qui établit 1,6
pour cent pour cette année voilà ce que
dit donc les économistes de saxo banque
jordan klein bonsoir stéphanie rôles
soir aux questions à michel soit bon
soir donc cet économiste dit que l'homme
bon sens il est difficile pour l'instant
de calcul et d'évaluer l'impact chorale
le break site sur l'économie française
est ce qu'il ya néanmoins deux secteurs
pour lesquels vous êtes plus inquiet que
d'autres sur les conséquences
globalement l'économie française
aujourd'hui
elle reprend des couleurs un peu l'année
dernière cette fois ci ça s'accélère le
chiffre qui a été cité 1,6 celui que je
m'étais fixé c'est 1 5 % enfin on est
dans les mêmes ordres de grandeurs donc
la croissance reprend en france sur quoi
cette croissance en france est elle
fondée d'abord sur la consommation des
ménages
vous et moi tous autour la consommation
des ménages augmente fortement est ce
que le bric site met en cause la
consommation des ménages
réponse est non le deuxième moteur et
britanniques oui oui on l'a appris
aujourd'hui
oui mais ça du côté des buts mais je
parle de la france ensuite vous avez le
moteur 10 de l'investissement on le
cherchait depuis longtemps puisque
l'investissement des entreprises
s'étaient écroulés c'était une raison
pour lesquelles par ailleurs le chômage
avait augmenté cet investissement a
repris est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui
pourrait casser cette reprise de
l'investissement comme conséquence du
bras au ciel je ne le crois pas non plus
aujourd'hui
alors il peut y avoir des secteurs qui
sont très concernés tenez par exemple
automobile vend beaucoup de voitures
un nombre significatif de voitures en
grande bretagne et donc qu'ils se
trouvent tout de suite la question à
savoir mais si le pouvoir d'achat baisse
si le prix de mes voitures augmentent
parce qu'avec la livre qui s'écroule ça
peut faire augmenter le prix des
voitures
qu'est ce qui va se passer pour moi mais
c'est très sectoriel c'est la raison
pour laquelle sans chercher à me cacher
derrière mon petit doigt
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il n'y aura pas
de conséquences dommageables pour la
croissance française
mais il faut faire très attention et
comme le disait à juste titre cet
économiste nous le disions d'ailleurs
entre nous c'est l'incertitude qui est
la plus mauvaise cette incertitude qui
va peser monstrueusement sur la grande
bretagne mais qui bien entendu pèse
aussi sur le reste de leurs c'est quoi
la rue le risque alors concrètement la
de 7,1 cm quand vous avez une
incertitude avait des gens regardaient
prenons en prenant des gens qui
investissent en europe mais qui sont pas
en france ou en grande-bretagne mais qui
sont au japon ou en chine
quand il regarde ça de loin ils disent
pas la grande bretagne seulement ils
disent l'europe dans l'europe il se
passe des choses et des choses donc ils
se tiennent sur le bord ils vont pas
prendre la décision qu'il avait souhaité
prendre c'est cette incertitude que nous
voulons briser le plus rapidement
possible dans le secteur bancaire plus
spécifiquement qu'est ce que vous
attendez comme conséquence est ce que ça
peut être positif comme le pensent
certains en ramenant une partie de
l'activité
à paris où est ce que au contraire va y
avoir une forme de concurrence par
exemple réglementaire qui favoriserait
la place londonienne
alors qu'est ce qui fait la force de la
place londonienne parce que la place
londonienne c'est considérable dans le
pipe britannique
qu'est ce qui fait sa force c'est que en
étant à londres on est en europe
on est dans le reste de l'europe il ya
par exemple des banques américaines
american américaines qui ont une filiale
à l'ombre ayant une filiale à londres
elles viennent faire concurrence à nos
banques européennes sur l'ensemble du
territoire de l'union européenne
c'était un une des raisons pour laquelle
cette place c'est beaucoup développés y
compris depuis l'entrée dans le camion
vers nous alors c'est bon que ça ne
servira plus à rien d'être à londres il
faudra avoir les pieds peu dans l'union
européenne chez 12 pts airs d'homme ce
petit franck fois c'était que les
banques perdent leur passeport bancaire
parce que c'est une chouette c'est la
conséquence obligé est obligatoire et
c'est pas la peine d'avoir des illusions
sur ce point c'est la conséquence obligé
est obligatoire de la sortie de l'europe
c'est un pays comme on dit en jargon un
pays tiers avec lequel nous avons avoir
des négociations c'est légitime mais
prenez la suisse elle n'a pas de
passeport ou ces banques n'ont pas de
passeport pour venir tant qu'il n'y a
pas d'alternative et aujourd'hui aux
banques américaines installées à part la
city focale gun en france sera la seule
manière de faire pour ses bons si elles
veulent continuer à travailler semaine
noté rythme et a contrario est ce que
vous risquez est ce que disait stéphane
est effectivement que londres devienne
un paradis fiscal est là en gagne une
nouvelle concurrence féroce
les places européennes mais pourquoi
aujourd'hui leur notez donc je landreau
ne pas fusiller essaie de raisonner un
peu pourquoi aujourd'hui londres
c'est la première place au monde qui
fait des transactions en euros quand
même étonnant puisque c'est justement
une place n'est pas dans l'euro c'est la
première place qui feront parce que ils
sont intelligents ils sont ingénieux il
ya des infrastructures il ya des sommes
importantes qui sont échangées c'est
l'intérêt pour beaucoup d'acteurs en
euros de venir faire leurs affaires à
londres mais ce sera fini demain il y
aura plus même ath type akira plus des
changes d'euros à londres mais ça va
continuer à considérer mans diminué donc
un an je sais où ces transactions vont
elles se faire et transaction bon 38 ter
moi je parle pas de tout ce qui peut
concerner la spéculation mais où ces
transactions ou une grande entreprise
qui a besoin d'emprunter en euros
peut-être aller emprunter
il vaut mieux qu'elle le fasse une
disparition qui a été votée dans le
cadre de la loi dite sapin 2 qui est le
reporting dispositions inquiètent les
républicains qui pensent que voilà c'est
trop de transparence et que ça peut
éventuellement avoir un impact négatif
sur l'activité est ce que justement
londres par exemple ne sera pas dans ce
dans cette obligation de transparence
pourrait en profiter alors leur porting
c'est la nécessité pour les sociétés
installées nord jusqu'en france par
exemple de rendre compte précisément 1
aujourd'hui la maison mère aujourd'hui
ce report thing existe y compris avec
londres dans le domaine fiscal
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui fait la fin des
mécanismes d'optimisation cachés où vous
pouviez négocier avec tel ou tel
gouvernement dans un tout petit pays
mais avec une très grosse place
financière de ne pas payer d'impôt du
tout et donc vous échappiez en quelque
sorte à la pause c'est terminé entre
administrations fiscales c'est
transparent
la question qui est posée aujourd'hui
c'est est ce que cette transparence
elle peut aussi concerner vous et moi ou
des ong qui voudraient pouvoir savoir
exactement ce qui se passe est au fond
d'un certain point de vue contrôlée sous
le contrôle citoyen je suis pas du tout
contre nous le faisons dans le domaine
bancaire
pourquoi pas le faire dans ce domaine là
simplement il faut pas le faire dans un
seul pays il faut le faire là aussi sur
le territoire de l'union et c'est une
directive qui est en cours de
négociation ce qui est prévu dans le
projet de loi sapin 2 c'est que nous
inscrivions dès maintenant les
dispositions qui sont prévus dans la
directive
d'ailleurs les revenants montagne et
chaqra par définition pour jusqu'à
présent elles mêmes très allantes sur ce
sujet là la grande bretagne et donc elle
peut parfaitement le faire c'est
d'ailleurs une disposition qui s'inscrit
dans un cadre beaucoup plus globale au
niveau international donc je ne pense
pas que ce soit un point sur lequel on
fasse une différence en dix ans alors on
va aller à londres
parce que là bas il n'y a pas de panique
c'est les entreprises qui doivent faire
ça entreprises elles sont raison des
activités en france c'est vrai pour des
entreprises d'origine étrangère google
ou amazon justement c'est ce qu'on est
en train de leur imposer alors savoir ce
qu'il faut pour pouvoir faire payer les
impôts qu'il vaut sur les emplois qui
pourraient venir chez nous est ce que
vous espérez vous venions pour être
clair là des délocalisations à notre
profit je n'ai pas envie de me lancer
mêlant sais pas ce que je vais trouver
très désagréable lorsque le premier
ministre avait dit mais je vous en prie
le tapis rouge est déroulé venez de la
france vers la grande bretagne
si vous avez peur d'être trop imposer sa
mère je devais oui je suis plus fair
play que lui part car je ne vais pas
avoir le même valeur au léger dit
l'autre jour que le tapis rouge rester
en place et qui pouvait fonctionner dans
les deux sens vous êtes d'accord quand
même avec valérie pécresse
la présidente de la région ile de france
qui elle déroule elle le dit le tapis
bleu blanc rouge elle a raison il faut
que la place de paris soit ironisant les
choses très clairement la place de paris
c'est l'ensemble de ceux qui sont actifs
dans les domaines des maraîchers dans le
financement des entreprises de
financement des états il faut que cette
place de paris aujourd'hui se renforce
la callas les capacités si des décisions
sont librement prises par d'autres
elle a les capacités de les accueillir
dans de bonnes conditions il n'y a
aucune raison de se priver de cela
ensuite c'est pas nous c'est pas les
états c'est pas une décision de l'état
ou de houe du gouvernement ou de la
place de paris que de persuader tête ils
avaient des armes quand cela vous
écouter ce que dit valérie pécresse va
écouter on a les armes de la conviction
et pas seulement écouter ce qu'elle dit
madame pécresse pour renforcer
l'attractivité fiscale notamment et là
vous pouvez l'aider je vais à londres
nous avons lancé une campagne digitale
pour dire welcome to paris frieden et
l'idée c'est quoi c'est effectivement de
montrer que paris par rapport à
francfort par rapport à dublin par
rapport à luxembourg a tous les atouts
alors bien sûr on a un peu trop de
fiscalité
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui avait fait dire
à boris johnson et david cameron c'est
qu'en france hollande a fait sa fameuse
l'action 75% tapis rouge à londres
rien ou c'est tapis bleu blanc rouge à
paris et je vais évidemment demandé à
françois hollande de travailler sur le
régime des impatriés l'origine des
impatriés vous savez c'est ce régime qui
permet à des salariés qui viennent de
l'étranger d'avoir un régime fiscal un
peu plus favorable pendant un petit
temps d'adaptation
oui je sais pas je ne fais pas la
révolution écrits en disant cela
non les différences de fiscalité elles
existent elles sont pas aussi
considérable et c'est pas ça qui ferait
un obstacle à ce que des activités
puissent avoir lieu sur la place de pai
a beaucoup d'autres éléments qu'il faut
peaufiner
il faut aussi des lycées il faut des
écoles il faut une capacité d'accueil
social quand ils ont la capacité de
faire la différence entre des images et
des et des réalités mais je réponds
juste sur la question des appâts trier
si d'ailleurs madame pécresse le site
sais que ça existe
donc nous avons aujourd'hui un
dispositif
i je suis passionné dire encouragements
évite de pénaliser un français qui a
travaillé à l'extérieur ça peut être à
londres mais ça peut être n'importe où
dans le monde
lorsqu'il revient il bénéficie du même
régime fiscal que précédemment là ce qui
est proposé c'est de l'élargir de
l'approfondir on aura un peu de
difficulté à le faire uniquement pour
londres si vous voulez donc il ya des
petits problèmes constitutionnels
il faut quand même traiter tout le monde
un peu de la même manière mais on
travaille à une amélioration du système
d abattre ils vont travailler sur le
système quand même alors on suivra moi
je suis avant de passer à la suite je
vais vous demander si pour vous le
brésil pouvait être finalement une
opportunité serre que j'ai entendue par
exemple le premier secrétaire du ps se
féliciter du fait que d'une certaine
manière une vision très libérale de
l'europe allait peut-être pouvoir
laisser la place à une vision plus
social démocrate plus conforme à la
vision française donc voilà est-ce que
c'est une occasion finalement c'est
toujours très difficile de deux labos
l'air de considérer comme une
opportunité quand on est une opportunité
c'est que c'est bien quelque chose que
nous ne souhaitions pas le break site
nous ne le souhaitions pas et nous le
regrettons aujourd'hui parce que ça crée
du trou parce que de l'incertitude parce
que ça peut être ça donne le sentiment
d'une europe qui se rétrécit alors que
notre vision de l'europe
c'est plutôt une europe qui a une
capacité d'attirance d'autres d'autres
pays dont je ne me réjouis pas de cela
je vais pas dire c'est superbe
opportunité on va pouvoir rapatrier etc
par contre ce qui est sûr on en parlait
au début c'est que c'est un révélateur
des difficultés de l'europe
mais puisque c'est un révélateur même si
tous nous a pas été révélée là il ya des
choses qu'on pouvait voir ou pas
auparavant
parfois même on a attendu le break enfin
le vote sur le break site ou avoir de
mettre des choses sur la table
aujourd'hui c'est le moment c'est le
moment de mettre sur la table des
propositions concrètes celle que je
décrivais dans des propositions vous me
faisait même leurs proches
en dix ans mais ça fait marcher livres
etc non on peut avoir un marché régulé
la régulation c'est ce que nous
souhaitons non pas la réglementation
l'état tatillon mais une régulation de
ces marchés pour que la bonne finances
la haye au bon endroit très particulier
dans la création d'emplois
vous parlez de régulation
en ce domaine de la loi travail donc qui
nous occupe le mans il en parle plutôt
de dérégulation ou du moins d'une forme
d'assouplissement
est-ce que voilà la nouvelle journée de
lutte contre la loi travail qui est
annoncé pour le 5 juillet c'est la
journée troppo non mais ça c'est le
choix des organisations syndicales en
jeu commente jamais les choix surtout
quand il s'agit de d'avoir une journée
d'action une journée de manifestations
ou des slogans en franchement on a envie
d'avoir des idées sociales ical qui joue
long des dérégulations non c'est pas
vrai pardon de le dire comme ça que je
le dis mais c'est à ceux qui utilise
cette expression là assouplissement la
réponse est non nous avons un système
très équilibré dans ce texte était libre
dans ce texte personne n'en parle
on dit voilà il ya des gens qui sont
contre mais on ne dit pas de quoi l'on
parle
aujourd'hui on n'a plus donné on propose
plus de négociation dans l'entreprise
avec des organisations syndicales qui
ont des capacités de négocier et qui ne
peuvent signer un accord que si elles
représentent plus de 50% des salariés
vous voyez des organisations syndicales
qui vont signer des accords contraire à
l'intérêt des salariés
quelle vision des syndicats quelle
vision moi j'ai beaucoup plus confiance
dans les organisations syndicales que
parfois certaines organisations et de
l'autre côté il ya le compte personnel
d'activité qui est une sécurisation du
salarié absolument conserver sa passe
est vraiment la bonne manière de faire
toujours pareil c'est parce que voilà il
ya débat il ya des contradictions que
certains vont au bout de ses comptes à
leur écoute et écouter les nécessaire de
mettre en oeuvre on a écouté aujourd'hui
entendues aujourd'hui les leaders de la
cgt fo puisqu'ils ont appelé à
manifester aujourd'hui encore écouter
laurent berger un patron de la cfdt lui
qui était sur votre ligne celle que vous
n'êtes départ lui il s'inquiète
justement d'un recul éventuelle du
gouvernement ce serait une grave erreur
selon lui
et donc la série tessi avait recul du
gouvernement sur l'article 2 elle sera
évidemment vent debout et complètement
opposées ce qui a manqué c'est le sens
de tout cela le sens c'est à dire plus
de place au syndicalisme à la
négociation d'entreprise sap a été
affirmée suffisamment la faute au
gouvernement en partie bien sûr en terme
de pédagogie et de sens donner à cette
réforme
moi je pense qu'il faut aller au bout
non et s'ils le faisaient pas je peux
vous assurer que la cfdt serait en
travers de la route
attention à pas vous mettre maintenant
la cfdt sur le dow a pas passé entre 10
semblait d'ailleurs j'ai entendu
utiliser les mêmes arguments que moi il
renforcer le syndicalisme c'est une des
vertus de ce texte je n'aurais pas c'est
devenu un texte symbole dont plus
personne ne parle du contenu parlons du
contenu et à ce moment là les choses
iront beaucoup mieux et il n'y aura pas
de recul sont parlants parquet de
l'article 2 c'est à dire la capacité de
négocier dans les entreprises la mise en
oeuvre d'un certain nombre de
dispositions pour s'adapter à la réalité
de l'entreprise fabrique une veillée de
prière en parler demain à matignon les
brian hill raja le recul sur ces
questions là il se peut qu'on peut
redire l'importance des branches dans le
système français ce qui est vrai qu est
réel même si elles sont parfois faible
dans certains de certaines dans certains
domaines mais bien de vous pensez
pouvoir de viser les accords non mais
non mais non non ça s'est passé mais on
va pas rentrer dans une mécanique ou les
branches autoriserait les accords
d'entreprise
là je pense qu'effectivement la cfdt
dirais c'est entre guillemets recul
non mais par contre on peut mieux
expliquer certainement quelle est la
fonction ces discussions demain c'est
d'apaiser de donner le sentiment en tout
cas qu'on veut dialoguer mais tout le
monde réclame le dialogue à juste titre
donc c'est du ce et du dialogue est
d'ailleurs d'un dialogue qui
manifestement était attendue et que tout
le monde sera là pour donner son
appréciation vaincu sur la situation
c'est pas le passage en force au passage
en force ce qui a manqué il est très
bien alors ces conteneurs ne parle pas
suffisamment du fond ici
d'ailleurs on a bien fait de tirer sur
le fond oui mais une fois qu'on a
détaillé comme ça pendant cinq minutes
hop on repart ensuite mélo est alors la
protestation des besoins vous dit pas de
passage en force mais il y aura encore
un 49 3 et vous savez les français ils
sont majoritairement suspect peut-être
parce qu'il préférait que les débats à
l'assemblée nationale se passe de
manière plus constructive mais elle est
comme ça c'est comme ça c'est quand même
ce sera en tout cas ce sera comme ça la
prochaine fois je n'ai jamais jamais été
de ceux qui souhaitaient qu'on utilise
de 40 autres mais personne ne peut
souhaiter utiliser le 49-3 voilà mais
après la dernière fois et si la
situation était telle que le passé elle
se reprenne vraiment faire autrement
mais avec un lancer de 49 3 merci
beaucoup
stéphanie le rouge troisième partie de
preuves par 3 maintenant michel sapin
comment françois hollande peut-il
regagner la confiance des français
nous sommes en onze mois de la fin de
son mandat et mickaël les abbesses va
vous interrogez là dessus mais on écoute
d'abord ce que dit à ce sujet le
politologue pascal perrineau à peu près
jamais sous la vème république on a eu
un tel état de divisions des gauches
donc le président aura beaucoup de mal à
s'ériger en pôle de rassemblement non
seulement de la gauche c'est quasi
impossible d'ailleurs on le voit déjà
jean luc mélenchon est candidat
l'extrême gauche roig qui se passe est
candidat madame duflot se prépare pour
être candidat mais aussi il aura
beaucoup de mal être le pôle de
rassemblement de son propre camp l'image
du gouvernement et une mauvaise image
donc c'est un homme seul exposé au vent
de la popularité
bonsoir mais qu'elle aimait ce bon sens
michel alibo semble se sa part dans sa
sur nos temps pascal perrineau ce sera
très très compliqué c'est même pire que
ça si on l'écoutera l'aquila pocket avis
aux plus qu'à rentrer chez soi c'est
l'apocalypse
donc il a un peu dans son rôle de
comment dirais-je de prophètes de
mauvais augure
or il n'a pas tort surtout si la vie de
dire aujourd'hui que la situation est
difficile et en particulier difficile
pour le président de la république la
réponse est oui
les difficiles est ce qu'une situation
difficile est une situation qui rend
impossible toute évolution dans les mois
qui viennent la réponse est non c'est
d'ailleurs même le coeur de l'action
politique
l'action politique c'est pas de
constater qu'il se passe quelque chose
aujourd'hui et que forcément dans neuf
mois
ça sera la même situation l'action
politique c'est de faire bouger cette
occasion la faire évoluer et en
l'occurrence dans le sens que l'on
souhaite que moi je souhaite dire une
candidature du président de la
république dans des conditions qui lui
permet de faire valoir son travail de
faire valoir ses résultats de fer blanc
ces propositions que je devrais qu'est
ce qui pourrait empêcher aujourd'hui une
candidature de françois hollande lui
s'il décide de faire autrement
et dans ces cas là il se passe quoi mais
je me donne je ne raisonne pas comme ça
donc je vais vous poser la question
qu'est ce qui peut l'empêcher lui parce
qu'il est libre d'être candidat ou de ne
pas être candidat je souhaite
profondément qui le sommet pour une
raison simple tu es très terre à terre
peuvent apparent le fait d'être un peu
concret je ne vois pas d'autre candidat
à gauche qui pourrait mieux certains
diraient partant de d'une situation
difficile mais pourrait mieux rassembler
la gauche que lui je ne vois pas
d'ailleurs à chaque fois qu'ils ont un
de plus qui arrivent je n'ai pas le
sentiment que ils soient plus
rassembleur que son voisin répond en
tout cas certainement pas plus
rassembleur que le président public
aujourd'hui pendant sa première on se
dit qu'il n'est plus forcément le
candidat naturel
non je ne pense pas cela je répète que
un président de la république sortant
est assez naturellement considéré comme
le candidat comme candidat à senna
rivoire et romance par une primaire oui
mais c'est une primaire de même nature
que celle que nous avions auparavant ce
une primaire pour rassembler une
primaire si si si il y à une primaire si
le président républicain candidat etc
mais c'est une primaire pour rassembler
et je pense que c'est bien vu ce qu'on
appelle la gauche de gouvernement
c'est à dire celles qui aujourd'hui
participent à l'action
je dis pas celle qui est contente
heureusement la gauche mais j'espère que
la gauche qui fait le gouvernement
j'espère que s'il y a des primaires les
primaires dans les conditions qui ont
été proposées par le parti socialisme
par s
solide il y aura des candidats est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que ceux
qui sont candidats
ils s'engagent à une chose est à une
seule c'est de soutenir celui qui le
gagnera la prime est sacré vous savez ça
s'est passé le principe c'est celui que
nous avions la gauche réconciliation qui
rentre dans cette primaire est
réconciliables par définition puisque
dans une primaire de la gauche de
gouvernement
ils s'engagent à soutenir celui qui aura
été décidé si c'est pour ça que c'est un
certain moment le premier moment de
rassemblement
perrino disait c'est très difficile pour
lui de rassembler wes pas simple mais ça
c'est une âme au mans le jour venu qui
permettra je pense sera autre chose
c'est d'avoir un camp fracturé en face
de vos sais pas si c'est notre chance la
face de l'aréna
c'est la réalité tous les jours y en a
une plus que le même territoire avec les
mêmes arguments
je suis pas sûr que ça apporte beaucoup
au débat politique globale enfin ça
montre la diversité n'a trop de celle
qu'on appelle parfois l'autre gauche non
pas dans l'oeil gauche de gouvernement
j'en vois pas d un nombre considérable
il y en aura suffisamment pour qu'il y
ait un vrai débat et qu' il ya un vrai
choix encore une question sur cette
première vous avez dit solidaire de
boulgour dans le journal le monde
aujourd'hui dans une unité a lieu dit il
fixe à peu ses conditions pour y
participer il veut dix mille bureaux de
vote le même système de parrainage qu'en
2011 des listes électorales de la
république donc on sommes tous les
électeurs et en somme il dit que cette
première année pas loyal mais je sais
pas comment il peut enfin si on voit
bien que c'est une forme d'échappatoire
que de considérer à l'avant ce que
quelque chose n'est pas loyal c'est une
manière en quelque sorte dès maintenant
d'annoncer qu'on est capable d'être
candidat hors de la primaire mais s'il
veut être candidat hors de leurs
primaires il le sera avec 15 autres
ça vous inquiète 15 mais non ça
m'inquiéterait si j'étais parmi les 15
autres mais je me dis parmi quinze
autres si par contre il veut et on peut
le souhaiter
construire un premier étape de
rassemblement avec ses différences et
s'inscrire dans la primaire qui sera
organisée par le parti socialiste dans
des conditions qui n'ont pas de réaction
pas fixé mais qui n'ont pas de raison
d'être fondamentalement différente des
précédentes
à ce moment-là il commencera à
participer au rassemblement je préfère
un montebourg participant à sa manière
au rassemblement cas montebourg qui en
rajoute dans la division de l'état de
faiblesse du chef de l'état aujourd'hui
dans l'opinion
1 est ce que vous pensez que le premier
handicap c'est de pouvoir franchir le
premier tour
et ça c'est rien n'est gagné et là vous
dites évidemment problème de toute
mesure mais plutôt de gauche d'être
gauche comme de droite
heureusement dans le paysage politique
parce que quand nous disons cela nous
disons quoi que nous avons une forme de
certitude que une personne sera conduite
rats sera présente au deuxième tour
c'est ça votre collection
c'est le reflet de la c'est le reflet de
la réalité politique d'aujourd'hui
j'espère qu'elle peut être bouger
qu'elle peut être modifié je pense que
des arguments qui permettent aujourd'hui
madame le pen d'avoir autant de
recueillir autant de voix c'est une
réalité sont des arguments là aussi le
débat britannique va aider sont des
arguments fallacieux sont les arguments
qui entraîne dans un domaine qui est
quelqu'un qui est dangereux y compris
pour vous une bonne partie de ceux qui
sincèrement votre vote pour elle donc
j'espère que le combat la bataille
électorale celle des propositions
permettra de faire baisser
considérablement le front national et je
souhaite évidemment qu'il y est un homme
de gauche ou une femme de gauche qui
soit présente au deuxième tour de ces
élections je me battrai pour ça et je
pense je le répète qu'elle préside la
république est le mieux placé pour ça
mais je vais pas vous évidemment vous
montrer tous les sondages du couple
exécutif mais c'est vrai que et le
présent de la république et le premier
ministre pour metz et dérives ou que
françois hollande mais est victime
quelque part de l'intransigeance de son
premier ministre
non je pense pas du tout je pense qu'il
ya une complémentarité entre entre les
deux qui est tout à fait utile qui est
bienvenu qui est efficace
moi je ne veux pas de problèmes mais oui
l'exécutif est impopulaire entre
guillemette d'après vos sondages j'ai
tendance parfois à dire que tant qu'on
n'est pas arrivé en dessous de 3% qui
est le chiffre à partir duquel chine
symbole dans ce col mais oui c'est
symbolique parce que françois hollande
est parti avec un sondage à 3% partie la
dernière fois enfin vous marier quant à
elle 3 % des partis en campagne et à
l'époque qu'est ce que vous disiez mais
qu'est ce que c'est que cette candidate
avec les sondages bilan c'est fait pour
être démenties d'accord alors écoutez il
ya aussi un facteur important de la
division à gauche c'est ce qui se passe
dans le camp écologiste je vous propose
d'écouter le sénateur ronan dantec qui
réagissaient tout à l'heure notamment
sur le vote en faveur de l'aéroport
notre dame des landes mai
il fait une espèce d'amalgamé enfin
écoutez vous pourrez réagir
je crois que françois hollande qui a
aujourd'hui volonté de rassembler son
électorat doit entendre le message de
ses électeurs doit entendre le message
de cette consultation est joué
l'apaisement avec le brix y avait de la
loi les conneries on peut pas ouvrir un
nouveau front
donc moi je suis prêt encore une fois à
m'asseoir autour d'une table avec des
partisans du projet pour trouver des
solutions
on relate résout moi je ne ressens pas
comme ça se trouve c'est assez
constructif sur la fin je suis prêt à
mettre autour d'une table avec les
partisans bien ce que ne fait pas alors
que d'autres le font c'est qu'ils ne met
pas en cause la légitimité de cette
consultation il ya une consultation
c'est bien elle a donné un résultat
clair les habitants sont favorables à la
construction de ce nouvel aéroport est
ce que ça résout tous les problèmes non
il ya aussi des problèmes très pratique
très concret qu'on discute de ses
problèmes pratiques sur la manière la
mise en oeuvre de ces travaux somme
paraît parfaitement légitime donc je ne
vois pas et d'ailleurs je le connais
bien et je rêvais bien son tempérament
et sa manière de près je ne vois pas
qu'ils en rajoutent si je puis dire dans
la division quelque chose de cassé de 80
cas plutôt d'aider des éléments là
positif dans son disque de repas quelque
chose de cassé mais quand même avec les
écologistes avec les verts dans leur
ensemble à gauche il ya une chose qui
est certaine c'est quelque chose de
cassé entre eux et de casser lourdement
entre donc c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire savoir un vrai problème
pour vous c'est pas franchement ce
serait un problème pour elle
ah bon oui mais comme ça a été toujours
le cas pour les candidatures et que
l'eau présidentielle qui s'est pas la
bonne élection
par contre que l'on non seulement que
l'on tienne compte que l'on soit dans la
conviction écologique sur un ensemble de
sujets c'est absolument nécessaire
il ne peut pas y avoir aujourd'hui de
politique bonne pour les français les
européens qui s'abstrait de ces
questions écologiques regardait la
manière dont le président a fixé ces
battues à juste titre et avec réussite
autour de comment faire face au défi
climatique
comment éviter un réchauffement de la
planète profondément préjudiciable pas
seulement pour les générations même déjà
parce que pour nous aujourd'hui c'est un
combat ça c'est un combat écologique au
bon sens du terme et qui en plus
compréhensible par les français
il ya beaucoup de combats écologiques
qui sont totalement incompréhensibles ce
qu'on envoie des termes vivent là
vraiment dans la stratosphère où entre
eux il arrive à se comprendre et encore
il arrive à débattre mais les français
n'y comprennent rien mais c'est sympa je
voudrais vous parler d'un ministre qui
travaillent pas très loin de chez vous
et merci
le 12 juillet emmanuel macron à tenir un
meeting à la mutualité et la même annulé
deresmes annulé un déplacement
diplomatique en sommes pour pouvoir
tenir ce meeting est ce normal
comme dirait quelqu'un c'est un homme
politique donc lille agir d'hommes
politiques
les hommes politiques les hommes
politiques ils le font du porte-à-porte
les hommes politiques
il s'exprime sur des sujets même parfois
sur des sujets lorsqu ils sont ministres
qui dépassent leur leur territoire
propre et quand on est un homme
politique on peut tenir des meetings
donc il tient des meetings se connecter
et d'autre il en fait trop ou quelque
part sur l'entente entre les lignes pour
un ministre il en fait beaucoup
ouais en dehors de ses activités à
verser quoi le voyez quand même encore
oui bien sûr et j'étais et je lui dis
d'ailleurs les choses de la même manière
je pense est un bon ministre
c'est qu'elle est vous êtes papa alors
viser quelqu'un non seulement aux quais
du talent parce qu'on n'arrête pas dire
qu'il a du talent mais quart d'avenir
qui accueille quelque chose que vous
évoquez la même chose mais il faut qu'il
soit clair il est dans la gauche a il
dans un gouvernement de gauche et donc
et à gauche donc il paraît puisque dans
un gouvernement de gauche
il faut pas qu'ils hésitent à le dire
d'accord vous trouvez qu'il devrait
peut-être te dire davantage alors on se
connaît dans la vie politique
d'aujourd'hui il faut pas être dans la
précision est ce qu il a raison de
penser qu'ils le 2017 et près de 100
tours déjà je sais pas s'ils le font on
me l'a jamais dit on va dire ben écoutez
vous l'a pas dire un poisson le fond si
vous êtes d'accord
il a appelé à réformer lisf afin de
doper l'investissement productif la
raison est une très bonne réponse qui a
été faite par le secrétaire d'état au
budget qui ne connaît bien tous ces
sujets l'investissement productif il
n'est pas soumis à l'isf qui c'est cher
mais manuel mata où il a une vision qui
est un peu un peu c'est pas exactement
la réalité des choses
il faut pas confondre leurs revenus et
le capital des personnes avec le capital
d'une entreprise c'est qu'ils montent
nature alors vous avez dit tout à
l'heure vos espoirs pour
2017 avec françois hollande il ya un
responsable politique a une certitude
pour 2017
c'est bien ce nicolas sarkozy il est sûr
de l'alternance qu'en pensez vous je
pense qu'il a été souvent victimes de
ces certitudes non par le passé on peut
pas être simplement dans la certitude
c'est normal quand on veut être candidat
on a plutôt envie de se battre pour
gagner donc c'est pas ça il faut qu'il
fasse attention avec les certitudes
surtout quand les certitudes ne sont pas
argumenté je reviens sur ce que je
disais au début il dit il faut d'ici la
fin de l'année un nouveau traité très
bien peut-être ça peut être nécessaire
mais quoi dedans je ne les ai pas
entendus nous dire quelles étaient ses
propositions pour une europe rénové pour
une europe plus dynamiques ou une europe
acquis à laquelle on redonne à l'avenir
je ne l'ait pas entendu dire un mot de
cela qu'il nous parle du fond ça vous
touche quand il dit ou quand même
d'autres disent à droite qu'il n'y a pas
de chef à la tête de l'état celle un
slogan là aussi c'est juste une manière
de blessés c'est sans importance
vous avez lu les programmes chez les
ingénues sion la cinquième république
elles font qu' à chef de l'état vous
avez lu j'imagine les programmes ou lieu
en tout cas les programmes et d'ailleurs
qui viennent quand il vient rencontrer
le chef de l'état il appelle monsieur le
président de république donc
manifestement même pour lui il ya un
chef à la tête de l'état je comprends la
question vous avez vu vous avez lui les
programmes des candidats nicolas sarkozy
par exemple il promet un choc fitial de
25 milliards d'euros dès 2010 est
qu'elle y feriez cette politique comme
de guara de colombie responsable des
baisses de 25 milliards tout de suite
ses 25 milliards de déficit de plus
alors on en revient au sérieux
budgétaire mais c'est pas la peine de
demander à la commission de dire ce
qu'il faut faire ou pas faire c'est
aberrant irresponsable parce que ou
alors il faudrait que la même année il
baisse de 25 milliards les dépenses
il va m'expliquer où il baisse de 25
milliards en un an les dépenses alors
que par ailleurs il réclame
peut-être at-il raison plus de moyens
pour la police alors qu'il a beaucoup
détruit
de moyens de la police plus de moyens
pour l'armée il y en a besoin nous les
augmentons plus de moyens pour la
justice bref donc aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est ce type de promesses
c'est la démagogie maximale un génie
fermage et les impôts
je vous promets de baisser les impôts et
vous allez faire comment on verra plus
tard ballon propositions qui sont
parlées à partir de là une crédibilité
économique qui est atteinte et à partir
de là des conséquences très graves pour
la france en terme de taux d'intérêt je
veux pas revenir sur tous les aspects
techniques mais c'est pour ça que c'est
totalement irresponsable
est-ce que la jupe et plus responsable
ça voulait dire exactement
vous avez envie d'en parler alesi et
bien scellé les électeurs de la primaire
à droite qui vont le dire vous êtes
spécialiste vous avez lu je ne suis pas
électeurs de la primaire à droite maker
de stries électeurs de la primaire est
dans tous les cas on ne sait pas quel
sera le thème de la campagne du candidat
que vous avez envie de voir se
représenter en 2017 mais on a déjà
entendu aux angles d'attaqué contre la
droite
il aura d'autres vous y travaillez déjà
l'avantagé une campagne électorale c'est
qu'on a pas seulement les yeux rivés ce
qui est normal aujourd'hui sur le chef
de l'état l'action du gouvernement mais
tout d'un coup on se met à faire une
comparaison entre on regarde ce qui
pourrait être fait en face et là c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles je pense
que les choses bougeront les lignes vont
bouger
ce qui compte on va faire la place à
réserver quoi en fait comment ça vous
laisse espérer c'est pas espérer c'est
le vrai débat démocratique je souhaite
le débat je souhaite la confrontation
bon sens du terme démocratique à la
confrontation des programmes la
confrontation d idées l aura lieu merci
michel sapin d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui
merci bonsoir à tous merci mais quel bon
soir a très vite